has India's move to revoke
indian-administered Kashmir this
autonomy put Kashmiri women in danger
those we've spoken to say they are
living in fear of sexual abuse and
harassment and statements such as this
one from a lawmaker from the governing
Hindu nationalist BJP government have
only made things worse Muslim bachelors
should rejoice as they can now marry the
white skinned women of Kashmir and that
kicked off a flurry of social media
posts from eager Indian men wanting to
go marry Kashmiri women did have a
reporter and sophie brendlin from our
social media team has been following
that story and so we welcome what have
you found out
so we talked really deep into a variety
of social media platforms and especially
on tic-tock that's a really fast growing
video platform that as of June had
roughly handled and 20 million active
users in India a lot of videos popped up
by Indian men who were declaring they
intend to do two things
a by land and Kashmir and be marry
Kashmiri women take a look we have a few
examples mirakuru theory this has real
tamari so Twitter was also flooded with
tweets of Indian men declaring the
intention to marry Kashmiri women and on
top of that they have released certain
music videos and songs which they call
patriotic pop and which have been shared
hundreds of thousands of times these
videos also celebrate the idea of
getting a quote/unquote fair skinned
Kashmiri woman like she's an object
without any agency to submerge media
women what have they been telling you
well obviously if you really objectified
and had a fast upon it's really hard to
actually reach anyone within the region
because of the lockdown but I spoke to a
woman a Kashmiri woman who was there
until recently visiting her family she's
based in Delhi and she actually she says
that women therefore you really under
threat take a look if you like a piece
of land in Dubai and it's like denying
women their agency
I have a control over your body now I
have a control over your life no you're
my property now so she says that there's
the sense of fear among Kashmiri women
that they'll be sexually assaulted and
harassed it's really hard to know what's
going on within the region because of
the lockdown but they are independent
journalists and reporters on the ground
who actually have talked to women and
they also say these women say that the
Indian military forces have barged into
houses and they have harassed girls and
women so these women are actually
preparing for the worst as Archie told
me with steel or copper utensils and
they would beat those so that they're
able to create noise and people from
around the neighborhood could come and
force these women out so the sense of
fear of being harassed by the Indian
forces coupled with this reaction by the
Indian men on mainland India they really
are leaving these women and fear and
making them feel really anxious and
Sophie Brandon thanks so much for coming
in and breaking that down for us